i needed to talk about the new laguardia
airport like i was talking about it with
a lot of people at the wedding they were
like oh my god it's amazing what they
did to laguardia is a disgrace it is a
disgrace to humanity literally i want to
walk one foot from my uber to the gate
that's what it used to be you could get
from your uber to the gate in literally
a hundred steps we got off the plane we
were wandering around this forlorn
terminal for 45 minutes a tunnel a
terminal a tunnel to another terminal oh
no you want to go to baggage club sorry
45 minute walk this way i was ready to
literally kill someone at the end of it
airports are not meant for lounging so
everyone who's like oh my god it's
amazing all these restaurants shut up
like you're dumb like you're literally
so dumb and stupid i hate the new
laguardia literally every person who
contributed to making it the concrete
that it is like deserves jail
for life i will never literally you will
never catch me my big fat ass in
laguardia airport ever again
you